wir schauen auf das blutbad am us
nationalfeiertag sechs tote bei einer
parade nahe chicago 36 menschen werden
verletzt und dass das ist der täter
roboter kripo 22 jahre alt möchtegern
rapper mit gewaltfantasien mehrere
stunden war flüchtig bevor am abend in
eine polizeikontrolle gerät und nach
kurzer verfolgungsjagd festgenommen wird
zuvor hatte er von einem dach aus auf
menschen geschossen mitten rein in die
parade zum nationalfeiertag in highland
park einem kleinen vorort von chicago
familien freunde kinder alle kommt
zusammen eben noch musik doch dann dann
rennen alle wild durcheinander und der
horror bricht los
sie sind gekommen um zu feiern
er ist gekommen um mich zu töten
der 22-jährige roberti grimaud der
dritte er erschießt sechs menschen
verletzt 36 es ist der
unabhängigkeitstag der usa überall im
land wird gefeiert umzüge finden statt
highland park ein vorort von chicago
gegen 10 uhr morgens sind hunderte
amerikaner auf den beiden familien paare
kinder sie feiern die gemeinschaft die
freiheit die stimmung ausgelassen
fröhlich unbeschwert die menschen
strahlen
dann der schock nur zehn minuten nach
beginn der parade peitschen mehrere
schüsse durch die morgenstunden
zerstören das friedliche treiben 20 bis
25 mal drückt der täter ab berichten
augenzeugen
feuersalven zerschneiden die luft panik
in den augen aller beteiligten sie
springen auf rennen um ihr leben die
schüsse des täters verletzten sie töten
menschen liegen blutüberströmt zwischen
liegengelassene stühlen kinderwagen und
decken
der schütze schießt offenbar von einem
dach aus es ist der 22 jährige robert ii
cream oder dritte ein erfolgloser rapper
er wohnt selbst in highland park er
flüchtet in einem silbernen honda fit
wird jedoch nach kurzer verfolgungsjagd
festgenommen
die bittere bilanz seiner bluttat sechs
tote und 36 verletzte
herbert bauernebel in chicago ist
irgendetwas über das motiv für diese
schreckliche tat bekannt
ja natürlich machte festnahme von bobby
krämer jenen jungen mann der hier dieses
blutbad angerichtet hat hinter mir sieht
man da eine der
polizeiabsperrungen hier mitten in der
nacht während eines gewittersturms all
das wird jetzt untersuchte man geht
natürlich auch durchs internet man sucht
die social media kanäle ab und findet
dort natürlich sehr viele gewalttätige
posting offensichtlich hat es in diesem
jungen mann gewehrt er hat beim plate
artige parolen hier abgegeben ja gesagt
ich werde es tun es ist meine schicksal
also wirklich ominöse drohungen die man
oft sie bei solchen massaker im
nachhinein zum zeitpunkt des postings
natürlich ist scheint das niemanden
aufgefallen zu sein und so konnte dieser
junge mann dieses blutbad durchführen
ganz besonders makaber ist die tatsache
dass er hier offensichtlich eine leiter
mitgenommen hat auf einem dach gestiegen
ist all das offenbar unbemerkt auch das
eigentlich ein schon ein
sicherheitsmangel bei einer solchen
parade und daneben von dieser stelle aus
das feuer eröffnet hat besonders perfide
natürlich dass man in kaum gesehen hat
dass praktisch diese schüsse kommt dach
kamen oder dass jemand wusste wo genau
der schütze ist die polizei geht auch
hier den tatort noch mal nochmals durch
es ist eine spurensicherung eine makabre
szene eigentlich denn das alles findet
statt zwischen kinderwägen die hier
immer noch stehen die nicht abgeholt
wurden auch spielsachen es waren sehr
viele kinder dabei bei diesem marshall
das ergibt eine wirklich mal kabarett
szene aber man versucht jetzt eben
herauszufinden was war genau das motiv
des killers
es ist es mitten in der nacht ist es
gesagt gewittersturm sehen wir hinter
dir aber wie erlebst du in diesen vor
ort nach dieser grausamen tat schon
wieder muss man sagen schon wieder
waffen in den usa schon wieder seinen
hut
ja das hier ist makabre weise einer der
sichersten bezirke oder kleinstädte
amerikas ein sehr wohlhabender vorort
von chicago
ist große jüdische anteil hier in diesen
in diesem ort highland park ungefähr 30
40 km von downtown chicago
und hier lebten einfach menschen um ruhe
zu haben um friedlich zu leben und man
hat es auch gesehen bei der vorbereitung
für diesen parademarsch zum
unabhängigkeitstag in den usa wie alle
fröhlich waren wie man sich
herausgeputzt hat alle die fahnen
getragen haben es sollte wirklich ein
fest der freude sein und dann alles
umgedreht in diesen horror in diese
schüsse in diese panik die ausgebrochen
ist als menschen um ihr leben gelaufen
sind all das spürt man natürlich jetzt
auch in den stunden danach man sieht
menschen die hier zum tatort kommen sich
das ansehen wollen es gab natürlich auch
sehr viele augenzeugen und sehr viele
angehörige die nach wie vor verwandte in
den krankenhäusern haben es gibt ja auch
sehr viele verletzten hier uns natürlich
ganz tragisch für die sechs todesopfer
beginn beginnt jetzt bei den angehörigen
die grausame zeit der der trauer des
entsetzens das nicht wahrhaben wollen
was hier wirklich passiert ist an diesem
sonnigen tag an diesem
unabhängigkeitstag in diesem kleinen ort
herbert bauernebel vielen herzlichen
dank dir für deine informationen